In this problem, we want to be able to split a string
by more than just spaces and white space but instead punctuation.
This allows us to better index a web page
so that we aren't fooled by punctuated text following a word, such as a comma,
and instead we are able to search for that word itself
instead of the word and the comma.
The first thing I do is initialize the output list.
This will contain the words separated by the splitlist.
With this variable I'm going to keep track of whether or not I am at a point that's a split.
This one might make more sense later, so let's keep going.
Using the for loop construct like this
iterates through the string source 1 character at a time.
If the current character is one we're supposed to split on, such as a comma,
then we're going to set atsplit to True.
If we're at a character that isn't in the splitlist
and we're at a split point, we're going to create a new entry in the list.
So if we're looking at this example up top,
if we just had a space and then we have a T
where space is something that we want to split on and T is not,
then we want to create a new entry that will contain what becomes the word 'the'
instead of appending it on to the previous one after.
If we're not at a split point but rather building up a word,
such as in the middle of 'After', we simply add the current character to the end of that word,
output [-1] finds the last entry in the output list,
and we simply append the character using the + operator.
Once we've gone through every character in our source string, we return the output list.